imagine you're about to embark on a high
seas adventure you've got your map laid
out and it's time to chart your course
now to make a decision do you stay close
to the safety of shore or do you set out
for deeper waters with the hope of
making a better time when it comes to
investing the balance between safety and
strong returns can feel a lot like
navigating choppy ocean waters right now
the stock market is at an all-time high
while most savings accounts are paying
less than inflation the destination is
clear to have our money make more money
but what's the best path to get there
what kind of return should you expect
from each option and how risky are they
if you don't know it's time to grab your
Atlas and sextant and start charting a
course to your financial goals
[Music]
the ocean of investing is huge while
we'd love to discuss everything from
cryptocurrency to real estate today
we're exploring investments that are
both popular and easily accessible to
the average deck swab let's start by
looking at the safest calmest course for
your investment journey Exhibit A the
savings account safe check liquid check
but with the average u.s. savings
account only paying 0.09 percent
interest you can start to feel like you
left the anchor down some banks offer
high-yield savings accounts paying one
to two percent or more
but with inflation hovering around 1.6
percent you don't feel like sailing into
the wind so while this might be a great
place to park your rainy day money it's
not ideal for long-term goals for a goal
a few years out you could look at a
certificate of deposit or series I
savings bond savings bonds currently pay
a guaranteed 1.9 percent interest and
can be bought directly from the
government at Treasury direct.org you
can start with as little as $25 and save
up to $10,000 per year but be warned
that you will be penalized if you
withdraw your money before one year has
passed certificates of deposit or CDs
are issued by a bank or credit union and
can pay even more between 1 and 3% the
catch is that there's a minimum deposit
of at least a few thousand dollars and
you can't touch your money for a fixed
period of time between one and five
years but as long as the bank or
government sticks around you can expect
to get your money back with promised
interest if you're saving up for a big
purchase like the down payment on a
house in a few years savings bonds or a
CD might fit the bill I've asked me
hearties it's time to head out with open
waters of public markets that means
publicly traded investments that don't
come with guaranteed returns or outcomes
make sure you've got some life rafts on
board
unlike savings bonds Treasury municipal
and corporate bond funds are traded on
public exchanges and since supply and
demand affect their value they have no
guaranteed return
one popular bond fund with a little of
everything has averaged three point six
eight percent annual growth for the last
ten years and like a stock fund returns
fluctuate and can even be occasionally
negative when bond prices fall think of
bond funds as a middle ground between
guaranteed investments and risky ones
like stocks often they're available to
you right alongside stock funds through
a 401k at work or inside an IRA these
can be especially useful for people who
are older and can't risk their whole
nest egg to a stock market crash or they
might be a great fit if you're saving
for something in a 5 to 10 year window
finally let's look way out in deep
waters the stock market with 16 major
stock exchanges in the world dozens of
industries and thousands of companies
traded across the globe it can all be a
little overwhelming but a highly popular
North Star for stock investing is the
S&P 500 composite index which tracks how
the largest 500 corporations in America
are doing over the last 90 years the S&P
has averaged a growth of nine point
eight percent per year if you wanted
your returns to track the S&P you could
just invest in an S&P 500 index fund
side note this is why we here at two
cents use a seven or eight percent
growth rate whenever we run the numbers
for long-term investing goals we assume
a little less than that 90 year average
with that growth rate why isn't everyone
hopping aboard
well the S&P almost never has a single
year return between five and ten percent
it's only happened twice since 1928
if you hopped aboard in January 2018
you'd have lost six point two four
percent by the end of the year one year
before you'd be up nineteen point four
two percent 2011 had a zero percent
return and in 2008 it infamously fell
thirty eight point four nine percent
whoo that's enough to make anyone
seasick
so short term investing with stocks can
leave you high and dry and is not
recommended by most experts but if
you're able to weather the storms
stay calm during dips and dives over the
next 10 years or more they may be just
the ticket so what's the best investment
it depends
earning 1 to 4 percent on money that
needs a safe and steady harbor is
perfectly appropriate or if you're
willing to take more risk and invest for
the long term five to ten percent is
pretty reasonable for 10 years or more
while it's possible to do even better
than this odds are that some extra risks
or effort will be expected and remember
to diversify so no single investment can
save their whole fleet align your
investments with the right goal hoist
your sails and you'll stay afloat even
when seas get stormy and that's our two
cents thanks to our patrons for keeping
two cents financially healthy click the
link in the description if you'd like to
support us on patreon any of yo songs
out there have some extra sailing advice
for landlubbers leave them in the
comment section below
you